epsilon r IG is a bright star in the
constellation araya the charioteer it's
sometimes referred to as all mas the
billy goat it's bright enough to be seen
with the unaided eye in most light
polluted cities it's also huge two
thousand eight hundred times the size of
the Sun if it were in our solar system
it would swallow Mercury Venus Earth
Mars Jupiter and Saturn in 2009 it will
undergo a rare event that only happens
every 27 years or about as often as a
man will stop to ask directions during
that event it will lose about half of
its brightness exactly why this happens
has perplexed astronomers for almost 200
years despite all of their fancy
equipment and computer models mother
nature continues to stump US on this one
what we do know is the epsilon RI g
likely consists of some stars closely
rotating around each other like
celebrities at a posh Hollywood cafe
exactly how many stars we don't know
they rotate within a single flat plane
just like our solar system from Earth we
see the plane as edge on sometimes one
star blocks the light from the other
causing the entire system to drop in
total brightness astronomers call these
eclipsing binary stars imagine two stars
on a spinning frisbee when you look at
it from the top you see light from both
stars now imagine looking at the frisbee
from the side sometimes you'll see the
light from both stars but sometimes one
star will be in front of the other then
you only see the light from one this
makes the system seem fainter
astronomers call this an eclipse hence
the name eclipsing binary in systems
like this the more massive stars called
the primary and the less massive stars
called the secondary think of Laurel and
Hardy the primary is Hardy and the
secondary is Laurel the problems with
epsilon RI g lie mostly with the
secondary star during the Eclipse it
seems to disappear one of the most
powerful tools in astronomy is the
spectrograph it allows astronomers to
brake light into its component wave
lengths the primary star in the
secondary star should have different
types of spectra because they're
different types of stars so when the
secondary Eclipse is the primary we
should see the primary spectra diminish
and the secondary spectra increase in
relative strength imagine shining red
and blue light bulbs next to a wall the
light on the wall would look purple now
move the red light in front of the blue
one much of the blue light would be
blocked by the red light bulb but some
of it would still pass by as a result
the light on the wall would become
purplish red since it now has more red
than blue light but with epsilon R IG
there's no spectral evidence of the
secondary that is astronomers detect no
new spectra during the eclipse they only
see the primary spectra it's as if the
secondary wasn't there this plus other
observational evidence has led
astronomers to theorize that the
secondary is not actually a simple star
but something much more complex and
maybe one or even two stars surrounded
by a perpetual dust cloud like Pigpen so
some scientists think we have a dust
cloud that has one or more stars within
it altogether orbiting the huge primary
star the Eclipse lasts about a year and
a half and about midway through the
Eclipse the star quickly and briefly
regains a portion of its brightness this
may be evidence of a hole in the dust
cloud allowing extra light through it
now here is the most bizarre part in
addition to the Eclipse the star seems
to pulsate and brightness that is every
few months it seems to gain and lose a
tiny bit of light but over the last few
decades this pulsation cycle has dropped
from about three months to about two
months this could be caused by an
unknown object perhaps a planet or proto
planet spiraling into the star as it
spirals in it moves faster and faster if
it continues at its current pace then it
would impact the star by the middle of
the 21st century or perhaps sooner if so
it may cause some very exciting
interstellar fireworks making it one of
the brightest objects in the sky or not
frankly astronomers don't really know
what would happen in such a scenario
they can only speculate and keep
watching we don't have a solar system
sighs a laboratory on earth to test the
hypothesis that's the beauty of
astronomy our laboratory is the sky
itself and it's open for everyone
willing to look up epsilon RI g is too
bright for most large observatories to
observe in the visual wavelengths even
backyard telescopes are overwhelmed by
the light of such a bright star that's
where you come in with the support of
the National Science Foundation
astronomers have organized a citizen
science project called citizen sky their
goal is to train the public to make
visual estimates of the star basically
you go outside and compare the
brightness of epsilon R IG with the
brightness of other stars then you
submit the estimate to a central
database such estimates are of medium
accuracy but when thousands of such
estimates are combined astronomers can
get very precise and accurate
measurements of the star so they need as
much help as they can get another goal
of the citizen sky project is to turn
participants into researchers we want
you to participate in the entire
scientific process not just data
collection you can process data analyze
it and even write a paper about it for a
professional astronomical journal which
is going to dedicate a special issue to
the star and if analysis isn't your
forte we have projects for artists
writers programmers you name it the
scientific process is very long and wide
there are steps in there for anyone to
contribute and we have mentors who can
help you on the way to becoming a
scientist if it sounds interesting visit
citizen's guide or